son las 8 y 30 de la noche en bogotá
quito y lima continuamos en directo
américa edición nocturna seguimos
comentando los principales hechos del
día a ustedes les agradecemos su
sintonía y vamos con los titulares de
esta jornada
en brasil las autoridades informaron que
detuvieron a un segundo sospechoso
relacionado con la desaparición del
periodista británico down phillips y el
indigenista bruno araujo pereira ambos
fueron vistos por última vez hace más de
una semana y expertos brasileños
realizan exámenes forenses a material
orgánico hallado cerca del punto donde
se perdió su rastro
la cornada y la principal organización
indígena de ecuador de dios' radicalizar
las protestas luego de que su líder
leonidas iza fuera detenido la policía
señaló que hizo buscaba a recrudecer la
violencia mientras que su defensa
anunció que presentó un recurso para
solicitar su inmediata liberación
tenemos análisis
el primer vuelo británico para llevar a
solicitantes de asilo a ruanda fue
cancelado luego de que el tribunal
europeo de derechos humanos emitiera
órdenes judiciales para detener su
deportación en el gobierno británico
indicó que no ha sido disuadidos de su
plan
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio en brasil donde
manifestantes se reunieron demandando
respuestas sobre la desaparición del
periodista británico don phillips y el
experto indigenista bruno araújo pereira
su rastro se perdió hace más de una
semana en el río y taco ahí en el
occidente del país y los hechos siguen
llenos de interrogantes hoy la policía
informó que detuvo a un segundo
sospechoso presuntamente relacionado con
los hechos previamente se había
informado del hallazgo de dos cuerpos y
el embajador de brasil en londres lo
comunicó a la familia del británico sin
embargo este martes el diplomático se
disculpó por transmitir información
incorrecta
donde están tom phillips y bruno pereyra
en brasilia un grupo de manifestantes
exige justicia y respuestas por la
desaparición del periodista británico
thomas phillips y el experto indigenista
brasileño bruno pereyra
es angustiante es uno de los nuestros
los que desapareció estaba amenazado no
sabemos lo que pudo pasar pero esperamos
lo mejor
miembros de la fundación nacional del
indio funai convocaron a una
movilización después de las
declaraciones de su propio presidente
quien dijo que la pareja no tenía
permiso para ingresar al valle de javarí
y lo acusaron de no garantizar la
seguridad de los trabajadores
necesitamos un cambio lo que está
pasando en funai es decir el
desmantelamiento la desprotección de las
tierras indígenas el fomento de la
violencia en las áreas indignas
el rastro se perdió hace más de una
semana a lo largo de un tramo remoto del
río y tacoa y en el extremo occidental
de brasil cerca de la frontera con
colombia y perú
en la zona miembros del grupo indígena
uruguaya y oficiales de la policía
seguían buscando en su último reporte
dijeron que las tareas se acercaban a su
final después de que descubrieran
pertenencias de los hombres cerca del
último sitio donde fueron vistos lo que
concentró las tareas en un perímetro
menor entretanto la policía federal
brasileña dijo que esperaba concluir
esta semana el análisis forense de una
de las muestras de sangre recolectadas
en la embarcación de un hombre
sospechoso de estar involucrado
previamente se había informado del
hallazgo de dos cadáveres
pereira viajaba en una investigación con
philips un reportero independiente que
ha escrito para the gardian y el
'washington post' y estaba trabajando en
un libro sobre la amazonía se
encontraban en una remota zona selvática
que alberga la mayor cantidad de
indígenas no contactados del mundo y un
lugar de paso de bandas traficantes
ilegales
en ecuador' la conaie la principal
organización indígena del país anunció
que sus integrantes marcharán hacia las
principales ciudades para radicalizar la
protesta tras la detención de leonidas
iza el líder de esta organización
con la policía esa fue capturado en
flagrancia cuando bloqueaba una vía y
supuestamente estaba incentivando un
recrudecimiento de la violencia para
analizar esa información conectamos con
andrés tapia gel es dirigente de
comunicación de la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas de la amazonía
ecuatoriana confenaie ellos también
participan en estas protestas bienvenido
a france 24 hasta dónde están dispuestos
a llegar en sus protestas y ya han dicho
que se radicalizarán las movilizaciones
muy buenas noches gracias por este
espacio es importante señalar que las
movilizaciones continuas se han
afianzado las distintas medidas de hecho
en todo el país y se exige la liberación
de leonidas iza mientras tanto las
movilizaciones van a continuar se han
radicalizado y pues prácticamente efecto
el llamamiento por los máximos voceros y
representantes de la conaie al
levantamiento indígena en el país pero a
qué se refieren ustedes cuando hablan de
radicalizar la protesta
bien el momento que mantiene medidas de
esto en 14 provincias
del país es decir más de un 60 por
ciento esto quiere decir acciones como
cierres de vías en el caso de la
amazonía desde donde me encuentro en la
troncal amazónica que cruza es el eje
vial de toda la amazonía entre otras
medidas que se han tomado a nivel
territorial cuando decimos radicalizar
significa que se van a afianzar este
tipo de medidas de hecho incluso en
torno a las ciudades capitales
principales de las distintas ciudades y
no se descarta tampoco una movilización
hacia la capital de quito sí pues no en
las próximas horas prácticamente no se
libera a la unidad y sol pero en este
momento usted lo está diciendo que el
principal reclamo es la liberación de
isa pero cuáles son las otras demandas
que ustedes les hacen al gobierno
en estos momentos obviamente por
puesto hay un conjunto de 11 demandas
que forman parte de los planteamientos
de que la conaie presentó al gobierno
nacional en dos diálogos previos que
existió durante este primer año de
gestión y que lo ha vuelto en estos días
nuevamente a presentar lo que tiene que
ver
voy a hablar con los ejecutivos en lo
que promueven es la ampliación de la
frontera extractiva estoy hablando del
decreto 95 y del decreto 151 que
básicamente lo que quieren hacer es
duplicar la explotación petrolera y
minera y la ampliación de las
concesiones petroleras y mineras en el
centro-sur amazónico pero también esto
se conecta con demandas nacionales sobre
todo por la situación que vive el país
una situación de asfixia en lo económico
donde pues prácticamente el alto costo
de la vida la elevación de los precios
de los productos de consumo básico está
pasando factura al bolsillo de los
ecuatorianos pues y esto está realmente
mermando la economía comunitaria la
economía familiar de igual manera el
incremento de los precios de los
sistemas agrícolas en el campo sobre
todo en la sierra está haciendo está
generando un impacto y una asfixia muy
fuerte entonces se plantea que debe
haber un congelamiento en esos precios
porque a medida que avanza en la subida
de los precios pues prácticamente la
situación se vuelve incontenible otro
tema tiene que ver también con el tema
de las medicinas los medicamentos de los
hospitales pues la carestía que está
teniendo pues es generalizada y es otros
temas que han elevado las protestas y
por supuesto uno de los temas centrales
el motivo la gran movilización de
octubre de 2019 el estallido social en
cuanto al subsidio a los combustibles
del precio de los combustibles que ha
seguido en aumento en estos dos años y
que ya pues prácticamente el precio de
la gasolina súper se encuentra en los
cinco dólares y en la gasolina extra y
la gasolina 10 del si bien ha sido
congelado producto de la presión social
no puede seguir elevándose porque caso
contrario siendo va a afectar totalmente
a la economía del país señor tape usted
muchas gracias esfuerzo análisis por
compartirlo con nosotros en france 24
en otras noticias la asamblea nacional
de nicaragua autorizó el ingreso de
tropas y aeronaves rusas a petición de
urgencia del presidente daniel ortega el
mandatario aseguró que las tropas y el
armamento que lleguen al país tendrán el
objetivo de luchar contra el delito
tanto en el mar caribe como en el océano
pacífico los legisladores también
ratificaron el ingreso por seis meses a
partir de julio de personal y aeronaves
de los ejércitos de cuba estados unidos
méxico venezuela y varios países
centroamericanos
fue así
un texto verdad de una guerra
anuncia está intervenida
[Música]
participando en talleres entonces crear
inquietudes crear dudas
en ese vínculo entre nicaragua y rusia
entonces eso eso
realmente lleva a que los países vecinos
ten preocupados y expresan su inquietud
alrededor de ese
y ese vínculo puede generar una
situación
peligro pues para su estabilidad social
y económica
de sus países en argentina la policía de
las habitaciones donde se hospedan los
tripulantes venezolanos e iraníes del
avión que se encuentra retenido en el
aeropuerto internacional de ezeiza las
autoridades continúan bloqueando la
salida de la aeronave que se encuentra
varada desde el 6 de junio cuando fueron
confiscados los pasaportes de los cinco
iraníes que hacen parte de la
tripulación el avión provenía de méxico
y su escala en venezuela y aterrizó en
ezeiza el miércoles despegó así a
uruguay a cargar combustible pero
aterrizó nuevamente en el aeropuerto
argentino porque uruguay no habilitó su
aterrizaje
finalmente no despegó el primer vuelo
que pretendía expulsar a varios
solicitantes de asilo desde reino unido
a ruanda el viaje estaba previsto para
este martes pero fue cancelado luego de
que el tribunal europeo de derechos
humanos emitiera una orden que paraliza
la deportación en caliente parte de la
política del gobierno británico para
frenar los flujos migratorios a través
del canal de la mancha marina sardenya
tiene los detalles
el primer vuelo que transportaba
solicitantes de asilo a ruanda desde
reino unido se queda en tierra así lo
anunció antes de la medianoche la ong
care focale este martes el gobierno
británico pretendía cumplir con sus
amenazas y enviar a siete refugiados
desde londres a kigali la capital
ruandesa el tribunal europeo de derechos
humanos emitió una medida cautelar
urgente para bloquear las deportaciones
forzosas de estos solicitantes de asilo
a pesar de los desafíos legales del
primer ministro británico boris johnson
reiteró su intención de continuar con su
política antimigratoria
esta es una parte fundamental de nuestra
estrategia para acabar con el modelo de
negocio de estas personas estos
traficantes que comercian con la
angustia y la gente suele pagar con su
vida estándar lloyd se estima que desde
inicios de año unos diez mil migrantes
han cruzado el canal de la mancha para
llegar al suelo británico pero la medida
de johnson para frenar este flujo
migratorio ha generado fuertes críticas
entre las organizaciones humanitarias
que denuncian un trato inhumano y una
política inmoral puesto que el gobierno
ruandés ha sido acusado por las ongs de
reprimir libertades de sus ciudadanos
además muchos de estos solicitantes de
asilo no tienen ningún vínculo en el
país africano
enviar a un país que no respeta los
derechos humanos es una forma de
evolución para las personas que se
arriesgan a ser perseguidas el fútbol es
quietud esencial de toda persona y
crispín persecución el gobierno de
johnson argumenta que su política
pretende luchar contra las mafias que
transportan migrantes a través del canal
mientras del otro lado cientos de
personas esperan poder llegar a la isla
en busca de una vida más digna
en españa se están registrando altas
temperaturas sin haber iniciado siquiera
el verano todo debido a una ola de calor
proveniente del norte de áfrica que está
azotando gran parte del país y se espera
que dure hasta el 18 de junio alva
santana nos amplía
calor mucho calor en españa' con la ola
de calor a más temprana del país en 40
años y la peor en al menos 20 los
ciudadanos buscan un lugar en el que
refugiarse pues mirad de esa clima tal
porque si este caso hubiese sido más de
ella no hubiésemos que el cambio sea tan
brusco nos hemos acostumbrado ya y bueno
más o menos es lo que tenemos aquí del
verano hasta noviembre con las
temperaturas de hasta 43 grados celsius
en el sur y también intensas en el
interior del país este fenómeno se debe
a una nube de aire caliente proveniente
del norte de áfrica y es peligroso para
la salud de la población puede provocar
desde desmayos náuseas y trastornos
cardíacos hasta convulsiones unas
condiciones con las que trabajar se
vuelve una tarea muy difícil no sabemos
cómo vamos a hacer
aquí
eso es que hay de momento
aguantamos pero creo
y es que cada vez hay más olas de calor
en el sur de europa un fenómeno natural
que aunque no está directamente
relacionado con la crisis climática y el
calentamiento global sino es su carácter
extremo y prematuro según los expertos
un aumento de la media se traduce
precisamente en eso en una mayor
probabilidad de alcanzar valores
extremos por lo tanto esa es la mayor
probabilidad se traduce en que realmente
hay más horas de calor se prevé que esta
ola de calor persiste en españa' al
menos hasta el 19 de junio unos días
antes del inicio del verano el 21 de
junio y la noche de este 14 de junio
está acompañada por la súper luna de
fresa la primera de tres lunas llenas
que se verán en el fin de la primavera y
la temporada de verano un dron grabó al
satélite natural de la tierra detrás del
antiguo templo griego más grande y
brillante de lo normal en dubai también
se pudo ver desde diferentes puntos y en
líbano se elevó sobre la capital beirut
se trata de la segunda vez en este año
que se registra una luna y recibe el
nombre de luna de fresa en relación con
la maduración de las fresas en el mes de
junio
y así llegamos al final de esta edición
de directo américa ustedes les
agradecemos su sintonía y los invitamos
a continuar con nosotros que ya llega a
andrés espinal con toda la información
de nuestra red de corresponsales en el
mundo feliz noche para todos
[Música]